Oh
your knee joint is made up of the lower
end of the femur which hinges on the
upper end of the tibia
and the patella or kneecap which slides
along the groove formed by the femoral
condyles total knee replacement surgery
is a procedure in which a painful or
poorly functioning knee is replaced with
artificial components if your physician
has recommended a total knee replacement
it is probably because your knee is
severely damaged by arthritis or injury
your surgeon will begin by making an
incision along the front edge of your
knee after separating the muscles and
ligaments around your knee your surgeon
will incise the knee capsule to gain
access to the inside of the joint using
specialized tools your surgeon will
remove the damaged bone and cartilage on
the ends of the femur and the tibia and
in most cases remove the underside of
the patella your surgeon will then
prepare the remaining bone to receive
your new prosthetic knee this generally
consists of a femoral a tibial and a
patellar component once the ends of the
bones are prepared your surgeon will
cement the new prostheses into position
before your incision is closed an x-ray
will be taken to ensure that the new
components of your knee are positioned
correctly your surgeon will close the
incision with stitches or staples and
temporarily leave a drain in place to
remove excess fluid